[Music]
foreign
[Music]
did
[Music]
stout here start by telling me how you
got this number
no more than your number where'd you
misplace the convoy
you shut him up
spill what you know don't make me wait
no not on the horn let's meet cut a deal
a deal fine first exit off skyline
driving towards the nid
storm channel under the overpass meet
you there
foreign
me
[Music]
ah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
look lively meredith stealth take it you
were the one to call
that'd be me
thought you could blackmail me [ __ ]
set conditions
any more for me calm the
[ __ ] down i just want to talk
christ meredith shut your trap
that [ __ ] thing ready
now answer my questions honestly
forthrightly
are you here alone
yep just little old me it's the truth
do a sweep now
now listen this piece of [ __ ] anthony
gilchrist
is he your contact is he the one who
leaked intel on the convoy
that guy never seen him before
listen i know where the transport is i
can help you
just want a favor in return
i told you i [ __ ] told you i'm not
the mole
jesus christ shut him up
unhand me now before i
him you can let go wanna hear what he
has to say
i need a bot flathead mob guys who
ripped you off have it
promise me that bot i'll point the
finger
you have a plan how to deal with them
could just take it by force
but they're expecting payment so i could
go that route too
fine the latter but on one condition
you pay with our money
sounds solid enough i'm in
they pay with that chip and that's all
you gotta worry about
try to [ __ ] me anyway
and i'll be seeing you real soon
you're making a mistake this gun's
already good at dead
i still take you down with her
all right
eddie's on the credit ship are clean
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
ah there you are
let me hear what you squared away
so dex already paid the mail streamers
for the corporal bot
thing is can't be sure the gang goons
are still willing to hand it over
he paid up front
well whatever let's go get this tech
you scheme yet you got a plan
militech and me we found some common
ground
they're footing the bill for the bot
there's a lot of scratch to toss away
forget it jack it'll be like we never
had it in the first place
anyway who knows how this deal's gonna
shake out
so into the borg beast then
let's go see these bastards all right
let's knock on their door see if they
even open up
i hate these borg [ __ ] it had to be
them she's a gang like any other right
i'll take the valentinos they follow god
and the santa madre
honor means something to me don't know
you
want to talk to royce dex sent us
yeah cozy place
they could use a few plants though
[Music]
oh yeah they look damn well prepared
don't think i've ever seen security like
this in the chow factory
gear from the jack convoy gotta be
must have been all over it like maggots
of dead meat
you hear about their boss royce dex
mentioned them
call them special that's militech all
right
cycle boards scroll down with
military-grade hardware with millions
anti-personnel mine directional shrapnel
spitter
my favorite subtle
get in the elevator [ __ ] [ __ ]
cool they're just trying to spook us
remember we're on their turf
so what do you want you got a bot
model mt-0d12 called a flathead
and there you can
guy i represent already paid brick for
it i'm just here for the pickup
i can talk direct to royce if necessary
now you talk to me name's duncan
now couch planet
[ __ ] ass on the [ __ ] couch
make me thought you'd never ask
say your ass down jack sit down
this ain't gonna end well but
[ __ ] well
all right
come on
thanks i'm good
whatever you say strange princess
t12
need to see it suit yourself
[Music]
[ __ ] tricked out this thing dynamic
thermo-optic camel armor
full cognitive immersion with a raven
controller
pin down prototype actuators made of
titanium vanadium kevlar composite
and watch this fully integrated link too
so when the spider starts crawling up
walls dangling from ceilings
could lose your lunch
so what you think
yep we'll take it free
sure yeah
let's see credit brick got it it's all
paid up
i don't see any [ __ ] brick around
here do you
[Music]
come on and expect me to pay for this
thing twice
and who the [ __ ] are you to say what can
it be
you'll pay twice because i say you'll
pay twice
all right you want the flathead i better
see some eddies
relax got him right here
just like that without batting a [ __ ]
eye
want it or not i got places to be
[Music]
you know you never did say who sent you
never did
say who you're working for dexter desean
that's it dexter desean
the hard-ass punching animal [ __ ] half
of pacifica
so you're gonna consider my offer now
[Music]
well i'll even toss in some info as a
friendly bonus
militech's on to you they're close
what credit ship was spiked with a virus
don't worry i wiped it
check it
yeah it's clean
all right rusty [ __ ] now i gotta deal
with this [ __ ]
you just take the damn bot and get the
[ __ ] out of my factory
if this is a trick i'm gonna introduce
you
nova so now leave and hey after you get
dex's dick out of your mouth
tell him i say hello
piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] let's get the [ __ ] out of here
[Music]
style i'd say
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
we'll write the production line flip it
[Music]
on
are you even helping us i'm not helping
[Music]
myself
ah
come on let's go
oh
[Music]
got no chance okay
ladies and gentlemen jackie wells
okay
careful
next
[Music]
all right
just don't swim
[Music]
oh
misery
point for you
go go
gonna blow
oh
now it all makes sense
so
the [ __ ]
the [ __ ]
shoot
oh
ah
hang on
[Music]
dragon
oh
shame to smash a pretty face
watch out
okay
game to smash a pretty face
my god
grip
it killed
wanted to let you know i like your style
here you go
you [ __ ] believe that guys
we can talk
i'd like a word with them
you shot at my people
they drew and fired first a fact of no
consequence to militech management
but if you'd worked with stout i'd be
dead by now
might not have intended it but he saved
my life
now i'm saving yours makes us even
appreciate it you're not half bad
caring for my interests not yours you
are followed
but i'm sure you know that stout's
people were on your tail
my people were on theirs in the end she
lost her nerve
thought she hopped in bed with maelstrom
behind her back hit the big red button
prematurely
classic when you don't know what to do
why not order an all that assault on a
food factory
about sums it up i made sure it blew up
in her face
business with maelstrom hardly ever ends
well does it
what happened to stout she placed some
bad bets her clock ran out simple as
that suffice to say you won't be seeing
her again
i think we're done here and doubt you'll
find much inside
it's pretty tough to get corpses to talk
you'd be surprised
i'm sure i'll manage something it's been
a pleasure
holy [ __ ] v i wasn't sure we'd walk out
in one piece
i think we're done what now
let dex know we got his toy for him fats
want to crack open a bottle for us after
what we did for him today
hey luego bee
got the bot and how'd it go run into any
trouble
and what about the militech angle sure
courser's trouble royce couldn't have
given two shits to you and brickett
shaking on him
how'd you get him on board
met with stout managed to strike a deal
gave me the chip with the scratch for
maelstrom i warned royce
we made a deal you got some balls mr b
what about the meet with evelyn parker
still on the to-do list
that meets the only thing that'll get
you a chance at grabbing that chip
park will be waiting for you at lizzie's
bar good luck
don't